were there any sort of metrics that you
measured that you thought were initially
important but weren't they were really
just vanity metrics yeah we measured a
hundred a hundred really pretty
intensely and we tried to do everything
right to get the diamond retention rate
but we found out that day one to day
seven retention rate drop-off was not
very important we found that day seven
to day fourteen drop-off rate was more
important than that so we just discarded
thinking about day 1 retention rate
after some time and were there any other
metrics that sort of came up or that any
other thing that you wanted to dig into
more that you weren't initially sure
whether this was going to be a good
metric for the company we did not we've
always wanted to find out how many
invites were sent but we did not know
the number of we were not really in a
position to differentiate between invite
sent by a new user as well as invite
sent by an already existing user so
invite sent by an already existing user
were more critical more important for us
which we did not think they were
important in the beginning but later we
found out that this two set of in why I
mean like this two set of user base was
completely different and they affected
differently on our product yeah